welcome everybody thank you for coming
to my lecture this morning I'm here to
talk a little about artificial
intelligence and machine learning mostly
I do neuroscience research up at Stony
Brook University in New York I'm also a
computational neuroscientist and I want
to be physicist and we our lab that that
I work in has a dual affiliation Stony
Brook biomedical engineering and Harvard
Medical School and our work is primarily
applying computational methods to
understanding the brain so very excited
about both I hope you're also excited
about these things and I will try to end
on time today instead of the grand
academic tradition of regarding time
limits I have nothing to disclose either
so seeing as how we're going to use this
as an introduction to machine learning
theory by way of the brain what we'll
want to do is start with some some
basics about neuroscience and so that's
important because in the brain
it's very optimized for learning and
thinking and so oftentimes forum
dictates function and the other way
around the brain is made up of cells
called neurons at the microscopic level
and all of these neurons connect with
each other there are about 80 to 100
billion of them they have a central bit
here called the soma or a cell body and
they have dendrites coming off of that
and all of these dendrites connect with
other cells and that's that's fairly
important for reasons which we'll
examine in a second these are actual
neurons they are stained collected from
a real brain and it's a pretty cool
image it's kind of chaotic so I don't
know if you can quite tell what's going
on but you can see branching dendrites
and you can see your your cell body and
the connections are there they're just
very small one interesting thing about
the synapse is that it's not actually a
connection so much as an empty space
that's the defining characteristic of
your synapse and it's it's an important
thing to study because a lot of
interesting things happen at the synapse
among them is information transmission
in the brain you can see this is another
slightly more realistic drawing of
you can see where the synapse is
relative to the other things and how the
dendrites in a receiving neuron connect
with an incoming neuron in order to
create these synapses so like I said the
synapse is responsible for this
transmission of electricity and that
defines information motility in the
brain so if you have this traveling
signal you have a small problem when it
gets to the end of the neuron which is
that there's this empty space the brain
gets around this empty space by
releasing a flood of electrically
charged ions that recreates the current
in the next neuron and it travels
through and then it goes on its way now
this information motility contributes to
this concept we call hebbian learning
hebbian learning says that when two
neurons activate simultaneously they
grow stronger between themselves and the
opposite is true as well
when they activate separately they
weakened this is also called synaptic
plasticity which you may have heard of
and it's an important thing because it
helps us learn things this is an
equation for for neural output so we can
look at how inputs come together they
get multiplied by that weight that we
look at and heavy and learning and they
all get some together and we get one
output so this this relationship that
we've defined here is subject to heavy
and learning rules which say that when
we get something that activates
simultaneously this weight will increase
so we're equation two if we have this
this generalized framework for weight
update in a synapse we can say that the
next weight is equal to the current
weight plus some change and we can fill
in the change with our heavy and
learning rule and so in this case I've
chosen a rule called Orias rule which
isn't really important it's just a form
of stable heavy and learning and it says
that the next weight is dependent on the
current weight plus this change which
you can see is dependent on the input in
the output so you encode that
simultaneous activation there and you
can index your set with multiple neurons
if you want the last thing that is kind
of important about having and learning
is that it's an automatic process
optimization and hebbian brains up is
automatic if we decide to increase our
synaptic weight it's due solely to the
activity of those neurons and those
neurons fire because they encode
some sort of stimulus response so if we
if there's a response that we really
like say a Fire's B and that represents
pulling your hand out of a fire that's
the response that we really like in
response that's stimulus and so the
brain says let's do this more often and
the pathway becomes stronger because
they fire together more often becomes
easier to perform and so that's how we
encode learning in in heavy ensign apps
as it's based on what we have learned is
a good response to the environment in
practice this is something called
long-term potentiation hebbian learning
is responsible for that it's a mechanism
for learning it makes to sign apps is
stronger and makes the circuit of
communication between the two and so if
we consider an environmental cue as
being represented by a heavy and synapse
and the response to that also being
represented there it makes sense it's
analogous to Pavlovian conditioning bell
rings and you get fed and so you
associate that with that and in the
synapse increases strength
so having laid some groundwork about
cells and networks and connections we
can switch gears and discuss machine
learning knowing that there are two
types of neural networks things that are
in our heads biological neural networks
and artificial neural networks are also
a thing
we can apply these concepts from real
neurons to computational neurons and
neural networks are statistical models
which identify patterns and so they need
to learn things about what they're
looking at about the data set that
they're dealing with structurally
they're very similar to real neurons
they have a number of inputs that get
weighted and all go towards an output so
you can see this this relationship is
preserved in an artificial neural
networks and your weights are changed
proportionally to correlate it and put
an output activity just like in
biological brains right machine learning
algorithms are also subject to heavy and
learning rules which is kind of cool
because that is one of the substrates of
learning and that's what makes learning
about data sets possible well it's
changing of weights our algorithm will
probably not work very well and so you
can sets that's your set of inputs and
it's going into an output so like I said
just like the brain and algorithm can
follow heavy and learning
you increase synaptic weight if a parent
neuron files
fires just before a child neuron and you
decrease it otherwise and weights are
the the pattern of information that's
most useful from an input it's it's what
the receiving neuron cares about just
like a heavy and synapse and encodes the
best possible response to a situation
and heavy learning is great it's
considered an unsupervised algorithm so
it doesn't require training to get where
it needs to go it works in a lot of
cases heavy and learning however it does
have its limitations and in the brain we
get around this by having this
psychological feedback mechanism we know
what is a good response to a stimulus
and what isn't
neural networks don't necessarily have
that so we need to add in an element of
optimization and the way we do that is
by training we look at minimizing an
error between a training data set and a
produced output that's a very powerful
tool but it leads the question does the
brain do error minimization so we
mentioned there's this psychological
feedback mechanism and in the brain do
we do training do we do error
minimization which is an important
question and we find that we do in the
brain there is a sort of a training
regime where we refine what our neurons
do and we consider something useful just
like training data in a neural network
and the methods are very similar there
are a couple of key differences right
and so to investigate that we've got to
revisit the brain but as a processor and
as we move away from hebbs original rule
right we get a little less concrete a
little more theoretical a little less
evidence driven but experimentalist sort
of funds we move on ahead anyway and so
to look at machine learning we do want
to look at what does error correction
and training data look like in the brain
in order to answer that we need to
examine energy and we need to know that
energy forms really good supporting
column in our understanding of the
universe and so it applies to the
generation of thoughts and and brain
activity as well we can skip parts of
this just that there's this idea called
free energy I was discovered by a guy
called hermann von helmholtz
and he drew an equivalence between
something called free energy and
something called entropy and entropy is
a very broad concept it characterizes a
lot of things including information
uncertainty information quantity the
difference between two distributions it
can also mean randomness or disorder and
so that's quite useful for us because
it's such a broad category that's united
by one concept and how most also studied
perception which is kind of cool kind of
a coincidence but he never United his
ideas which is unfortunate luckily this
guy called Karl friskin came along and
in 2006 he did unite the two by applying
studies of energy to studies of
perception in the brain he comes up with
this idea called the free energy
principle which is very powerful but
very complicated idea which I have maybe
highlighted here it's a little tough to
wrap your head around
however it's it is important to discuss
because it is a powerful concept as a
psychological model for learning and
perception the free energy principle
states that we avoid surprise by making
good predictions so in order to minimize
error or the difference between our idea
of something what we have learned and
the reality that we're looking at we try
and update our hypotheses about
something if I stick my hand into a fire
with the internal idea that it won't
hurt and then I'm wrong it hurts a lot
my model is different from reality
so I update it by saying hey maybe don't
do that that'll hurt and that gives you
some some idea of the maths behind it
it's not pretty well I think it's very
pretty but you probably won't and I do
want everyone to get to lunch on time so
we're not going to go into this but you
can get an idea of the actual
under-the-hood complexity of free energy
here if we're is if we like revisit this
slide we can see this application
entropy measures disorder in the brain
and the brain tries to stay very ordered
because that's how we maintain our ideas
about the environment and prevent our
brain from kind of decaying into chaos
and so we minimize our free energy first
and lays out this this world where we
can look at what's around us
learn things based simply on what we
look at we unconsciously realized we're
wrong and then we rethink it and he also
said cortical responses are the brain's
attempt to minimize free energy and that
learning emerges from changes in
synaptic efficacy that minimize the free
energy in the brain so he utilizes
plasticity to explain this change in
representation this updated learning of
our environment so we can use this thing
called Bayesian statistics to model what
we learn about something and how we
update our ideas about something so if
we have the probability of M our
internal model given Oh a new
observation we want to test how accurate
our model is so we find the percent
chance that our internal model is still
correct given some entirely new
observation and that's based on the
probability that we would see this
observation at all if our model were a
hundred percent correct it's also
dependent on the probability our model
is correct at all so for wildly off-base
this will be near zero or the
probability that we see that observation
at all so we can eliminate outliers
we've normalized it against that and
using this we find that we can update
our internal models about something and
because we store these models in our
memory and because sign APS's are
responsible for what we learn about the
environment through conditioning we find
that we can see these models we can see
representations of the data around us in
physical neurons we can change our
synapse is in a hebbian style in order
to minimize free energy because you have
free energy going into physical
representations of data because that's
how we store things so we can we can use
heavy an adjustment to minimize free
energy and that's based on this
relationship what we do is because we
can't go in and explicitly change our
weights that's not what heavy and
learning says heavy emmonak says our
weights change based on our inputs and
our outputs what we do instead is we
change our neural output because if our
neural output changes we can't change
our inputs they already exist if our
neural outputs change then our weights
will change
proportionally and so we minimize free
energy by updating our perception of the
world and we update our perception of
the world by changing the way we use our
neural synaptic neuron activity and so
if we we build a model of our
environment characterized by a couple of
variables we see what happens when he
perceives something is we try to
recreate this thing that we've seen
based on our model of the world in our
head and we need to infer some of these
variables like an actual data point V
based on our observation of the world
and so we have an expected data and we
have a function that maps that say we're
true we're looking at a 3d object we can
only see the surface of it and we're
trying to infer its 3d size based on a
light map we have an observation for
light intensity and we have a function
that says hey if you see a shadow around
a corner that's probably a rectangle and
so we can infer a data point based on
what the actual data is and based on our
observation and so we use that in a way
to model our environment if we have this
function great we can theoretically
figure out what shape anything is based
on our prior experiences so we come up
with all of these expected distributions
of these variables and we say we only
want our relevant prior experiences
because if we're looking at some 3d
shape we don't want to know anything
about sticking your hand in fire we
don't really care about that anymore so
we pick a distribution of only the
things that we've seen about light on a
3d object and that's encoded by this
variable thigh so this model of
perception is subject really to two
errors one is the new distribution that
we've chosen because if we chose the
wrong prior model then our prediction
will be wildly off-base and also our
error in our prediction because if we
say we see a shadow around a corner
and that's gonna be a rectangle but the
actual shape is a trapezoid then we need
to update our model and say well it can
also be both of these things and like we
went over that these models are
reproduced in neurons because that's how
we represent data in the brain we can
assign all of these variables to real
thickness in the brain for example our
input is our sensory observation U and
we have error terms
in neural output which are also states
on neurons and we have memories or
learning in the form of noise and our
predicted model etc so that's how we are
assigning what we look at and what we
think to the brain and then we can use
these equations to minimize that error
and like I said we can't go in and
change our weights explicitly what we
have to do first is change our outputs
and change our representation of the
world in order to change that weight so
you have reproduced right we've put head
into this mess and we've said that the
state of the neuron will change the
connections between it we won't change
connections explicitly and at this point
I'm sure you're thinking I never want to
hear the words free or energy again and
that's ok because if you're a little
confused so are a lot of people but what
we need to take away from this is not
really anything about that it's only
that the way free energy works is we
have a model of the universe and we want
to go in and update it relevant to our
new observations we want to say if I
observe something that doesn't agree
with my model how wrong is my model is
it wrong enough to be worth changing and
then when we change it how do we want to
change it to re-encode these new
observations and these new sets between
whatever we look at so with that we can
segue into machine learning because a
machine learning we are trying to create
a model for something we're giving a
machine learning algorithm a data set
and we're trying to find something to
explain what we see in that data set and
then explain other data
what we do is we pass in some training
data and training data is your ground
truth you have an input an own input you
have an own output and so we can
actually verify that our model works
based on this ground truth we can pass
in our training data we can get a
produced output we can compare it to the
known output and that's the same as what
the brain does when it perceives a data
set about the environment it's in it
comes up with this internal model of
what is going on around me and then it
tries and updates it comparing it to the
reality of what's actually going on and
that's how we actually calibrate what
we're looking at and how we're
processing data within our brain so what
we do is we come up with this actual
model that map's an input to an output
so we have a given input we map it to a
given output but we also want it to
represent other forms of data so what we
have is a function that map's old or
given outputs from older given inputs
subject to the condition that the
probability that your model includes
stuff from other distributions is near
one so all this says is we look at some
training data and we come up with a
function that map's an input to an
output we come up with some function
explaining how the data gets transformed
to get an output but in order that just
explains the data it finds patterns in
order to explain future data and make
predictions our model needs to actually
be good so we have this Bayesian
probability that our function is still
correct given new observations and
that's how we make predictions about
things and extend our model to other use
cases so I'll skip over putting machine
learning into a free energy architecture
it can theoretically done but I be done
but I don't really think it's worth
doing necessarily right now
instead what I'll say is machine
learning practices error minimization
just like the brain does it does this
both dependent and independent of
hebbian rules so independently would be
something like that back propagation if
any of you are familiar with that where
back propagation goes in and changes the
weights until there's zero error
between our training data and our given
data however we're more interested in
hebbian rules because that's the whole
talk but also because local computation
is very powerful and we see that in the
brain and we see how it's flexible
enough to really represent very complex
data so we're going to look at if we
recall equation 3 where we have this
generalized thing for synaptic update
we're going to look at trying to put
this into a free energy framework or
some sort of Bayesian modeling framework
something like that and we can plug in a
new hebbian rule something a little
different that satisfies our new
constraints that's called the Delta rule
there are a lot of different heavy and
learning algorithms and there are a few
that also do error minimization this is
the one that I just chose because I kind
of liked it in this case we use the
Delta rule it says that the change in
your model the change in your synaptic
weights in your model is going to be
related to your given outputs versus
your actual produced output and what it
says is if I've inferred a function that
doesn't yield my new output doesn't
yield an accurate output then my model
is wrong the probability that my model
is correct given this new observation is
much less than 1 because I haven't
produced the new observation my model is
wrong so I want to change my model such
that the intended output is more close
to what I actually get so I want to
minimize the difference between what I
make and what I've actually produced and
so I go in and I change the function
based on that and then that's kind of
what we've got with that it's easy to
get lost in the minutia and if you were
neuro scientists I'd say unifying models
of perception and learning would be
riveting but most of you are engineers
or data scientists stuff like that most
of your applications people so takeaway
for you will be probably zooming way out
and saying the human brain is really
really good at identifying patterns and
about learning things it makes the brain
so good at this is combining error
minimization and synaptic flexibility
that represents information
and then computes on it in the best way
possible and this is a very powerful
tool and that's how the brain is such a
good processor and how it can register
and learn about such complex data points
and machine learning models can use this
to a large extent and can make use of
error minimization and sign up to
plasticity as well as other things we
haven't even really touched on like
hierarchical structure and input
integration memory and stuff like that
but the parallels between one on the
other are no coincidence that's the
important point these mechanisms are
what allows learning statistical models
to explain data in both the brain and
machine learning and AI extends these
models to explain other data making
powerful predictions just like we learn
functions that are not just relevant to
what we're learning about right now but
extend to other scenarios as well and
the brain is flexible enough to function
in other scenarios and we are flexible
as people in other scenarios and you
know we have some some ideas for the
future about what other things we can
bring in and how neuroscience will
continue to drive AI and how AI will
continue to drive neuroscience and
whether neuroscience can ever lead to
more complex systems I try to stay away
from the C word consciousness because
it's very it's very ill formulated and
so it's very difficult to study but
there is there have been proposals that
free energy can really help us with
generative models and generative models
in turn can help us model consciousness
in the brain and eventually perhaps
apply one to the other it's a
possibility
it's way far in the future but it's
something that is maybe exciting there
are a couple of papers that I referred
to during the process of putting this
together in order of appearance mostly
they make for good further reading if
you're interested and I know I went a
little quickly and we've got some time
left so if you want me to go back to
something I'd be happy to re-explain
something because I did go very fast
through a lot of the Bay Z and stuff and
the free energy stuff and that can be
difficult but otherwise that's pretty
much it in the last few minutes I
can take lingering questions you know if
you have further questions yeah in in
neural networks on computers just by
virtue of not having a lot of
computational power they can be quite
large sometimes they can be hundreds or
thousands of layers of inputs and
outputs and that is very effective
however the brain is orders of magnitude
higher than that like I said there are
80 to 100 billion neurons in the brain
and all of them connect with each other
there are uncountably large synapse is
between those neurons and so it's very
difficult to recreate that in a computer
so one day maybe we'll be able to get
there and especially when you look at
the brain it's mostly regional the brain
is hierarchical in a couple of different
scales you've got hierarchies of passing
inputs and outputs from one sensory
region to another like you have five
visual cortices for example and they all
process visual stimuli together and so
that's very powerful because you have so
many weights and so many opportunities
to do computations that's very hard like
I said to produce in artificial neural
networks simply because of the scale of
it eventually one day maybe we'll get
there yeah
yeah we find that hebbs rules stick
around
sorry he asked what have we found that
is similar or maybe different from heavy
and learning that allows us to improve
on our knowledge of sign APS's and and
neural activity today what at what are
some of the differences in our in our
base of knowledge today and we find that
you know hebbs rules stick around
experimentally they were validated back
then and they do stick around today we
find however that there are certain
things about communication in the brain
that are less related to hebbs rules and
are slightly interesting so for example
there are neurons in which electricity
can jump across the synapse and so it's
possible that we miss some of the long
term potentiation in that case although
there is there is a lot of evidence for
long term potentiation across the brain
it's just not necessarily always based
on neurotransmitters and receptors
sometimes it's based on just electricity
jumping the gap in terms of neural
connectivity and neural connections we
find that there's a lot of connectivity
across larger regions than just neural
cells for example there are connections
in between different brain regions the
region of the frontal cortex is mostly
responsible for higher-order thinking
versus something like the parietal lobe
or even the temporal lobe the temporal
lobe is responsible for auditory stimuli
and there are there's connectivity
there's information transfer
between those two regions which is not
necessarily related to heavy and
learning because there's no sign ups
there it's just it's mediated by a
different type of neuron called axons
which are included in most neurons but
in this case they are much longer their
white matter tracts and so the synapse
is there are few and far between because
they're basically very long cables yeah
okay if there are no other questions
yeah there there have been estimates but
none of them are terribly reliable
because they're so difficult to measure
you know yeah yeah very small yeah
part of the loss of synaptic plasticity
in the brain is due to the energy
constraint in the brain so as we get
older our neurons get more resistant to
things like insulin which results in an
inability to sustain life processes and
so we can we have less energy to work
with and we can do less with this
synaptic plasticity and so that's part
of the reason why we lose that
plasticity in adults and we still have
it as children simply because our brain
cells are aging if we tried to recreate
that in a neural network I'm not sure
what it would look like we would have to
start with something that learned very
effectively because the way that humans
behave we do have those prior models
which we're able to learn earlier in our
lives and then if we tried to recreate
the the drop-off in synaptic learning we
could have some something that decreased
the ability to change those weights and
would probably begin to learn less
effectively and that's why it's so
difficult to learn a new language as an
adult for example so we would probably
find that model would start making bad
predictions and it would continue to
make bad predictions instead of updating
it as a younger model might be able to
yeah
yeah it probably wouldn't there would
probably be not much benefit from a data
analysis standpoint to modeling
consciousness although conscious AI
would be able to apply itself in in
other fields for sure things like sorry
yeah maybe but we find in other fields
like the the health field we find that
one of the big stumbling blocks to using
AI is lacking empathy I would I wouldn't
want a robot telling me I have six
months to live for example so perhaps a
conscious AI would outperform other AI
in in that sense but again I
consciousness is very ill formulated as
a problem and so it's difficult to talk
about solutions to it alright if that's
it then I'll leave this up here and I'll
let you guys go pretty much
[Applause]